foreign
Washington D.C hi Matthew how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve sir how can we help
hi so I just had uh I guess two
questions about retirement investing I
don't know much about investing I
recently started a new job and and
trying to set all of that up so I've
heard that you should consider your
current salary or tax bracket Now versus
what you expect to be in retirement and
then base choices off of that
um but I guess my specific questions are
is one
what is your advice on 401K versus Roth
or versus having some combination and
two what are your thoughts on a good
investment option or options once I
choose the type of account
um cool a little bit of backstory about
me I'm I'm doing
I currently set it up just out of just
blind guessing I'm currently doing six
percent in traditional and three percent
in a Roth I make about 120.
um so yeah okay well the first thing we
would tell folks to do Matthew is to
make sure you're out of debt and have an
emergency fund in place before you start
investing are you out of debt okay
I have about 32 in student loans okay I
would temporarily stop your 401k
until you get that paid off and I'll pay
that off with great intensity you need
to do that very very fast because I
don't want you missing this 401K for
very long very quickly beans and rice
rice and beans no life until you get
this paid off really fast okay like your
hair is on fire okay then once that's
done I want you to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and uh in your case that's going to be
like 20 grand and this is a fund you
don't touch for anything except for Big
Time emergencies
this is not I decided I want to go to
the Bahamas for the weekend fund
this is a an Emergency that's not an
emergency by the way an emergency is a
negative thing it's an unexpected event
okay so um right
then once you've got that then we
suggest you put in 15 percent
of your household income into retirement
and that's what we call baby step four
the first three are getting a thousand
dollars and getting out of debt and
having an emergency fund is one two and
three then baby step four is fifteen
percent of your income into retirement
that com is where we come to answering
your original question okay but that's
going to be more than you're putting in
now by the way so here's the way the
math will work out for you how old are
you
27. okay a hundred percent of the time
here's how the math will work out best
for you regardless of tax brackets and
there's a whole bunch of different
reasons because a lot of these groups
that write these articles do not
consider how people actually live when
they get to retirement and we do because
we work with people that are in
retirement that have a million dollars
in their 401K we work with them all the
time so we actually see what they do
here's what they do they don't use any
of it
the income off of it
is what they live off of if you've got a
million dollars they're producing a
hundred thousand dollars a year
okay all right and so you you know in
reality if you follow this stuff you
don't end up actually trying to figure
out oh Roth oh traditional oh back and
forth here's how it works 100 of the
time number one get all the match you
can get
because a hundred percent return on your
money which is a match
you can't screw that up with taxes or a
bad investment
okay
so always take a hundred percent return
on your money before you start a hundred
percent so get all the match you can get
then the second thing you do is all the
Roth you can get because Roth is tax
free at 27 years old when you get to
retirement 97 of the money that is in
your retirement plan will be money that
is growth
you will only have put in about three to
four percent and the rest of it will be
growth
the growth is either taxable or it's not
taxable
it's either Roth or it's traditional
okay and so you want it to be Roth if
you got a million dollars taxes is 250
000 no taxes saves you 250 000. pretty
simple equation
I like that okay so Roth everything Roth
until you run out you can't do any more
then if you still hadn't gotten to 15
and the only other option available to
you which is not true in your case is is
non-roth or traditional then I would do
it I would do some traditional so in
your case
you're going to take all the match
you're going to switch your 401k to all
Roth and then you're going to do an
individual Roth as well
to get you to 15 of your income because
you're probably you might get there all
at work I don't know no it's going to be
borderline though uh but yeah if you can
get it all in the 401K that's just fine
too then the last thing you ask about is
what to put the money in here's what
mine is in here's what Ken Coleman's is
in sitting next to me and here's what um
we've recommended for 30 years and it
continues to work I spread my mutual
fund investing in my retirement across
four types evenly 25 H ready growth yeah
growth and income
aggressive growth
and International
and I look for the fund in the selection
that I have in your 401k that has the
longest best track record
in each of those categories warning
ahead of time the underperforming
category of the four is the
international
it's not done as well okay but I I still
want some overseas I don't want a
hundred percent bet on the American
economy I'm trying to diversify across
types of funds and types of stocks and
over the Long Haul that'll play out
every single time I got a letter on my
desk that came in this morning from a
guy who started 19 years ago he's got
three million dollars and all he's done
is those four funds starting from
nothing all he's done is those four
funds
and
the weird thing was the letter is now he
spooked and he's wondering if he should
keep doing it that's just hilarious but
yeah no I'm 62. I got millions of
dollars in my retirement and it is all
in those four funds my I don't ask
people I don't tell people do stuff
different than I do it so Matthew your
new listener we're honored to have you
hang on we're going to give you a copy
of Total Money Makeover and
um send it to you and it's going to give
you the details on the baby steps and
the details on what we just talked about
I want to encourage you Matthew really
quickly because you heard what Dave said
you got this high right now you're on
the air you're going to get off the
phone and when Dave said to pause 401K
you said yes you nodded your head we
could feel it but you're gonna probably
have some friends and family members try
to talk you out of that to do both at
the same time and the reason that Dave
and we at Ramsey Solutions say pause is
we want you to get all that momentum of
having One Singular goal and that is to
get rid of that debt then you're going
to catch up you're not going to fall
behind at all but I just wanted to warn
him because you know you hear that it's
like going to a conference and Speaker
gets you all fired up and then you go
back to the real world and other people
who don't prescribe to this kind of
thinking of living or people who don't
understand why we teach we teach will
tend to be naysayers and you got to
guard yourself blinders on here blinders
on real life kicks in I mean you come
home from the marriage counsel marriage
conference and he leaves his underwear
on the floor I mean it's just real life
kicks in right I mean that's just how it
works and so you're that's a good
warning and um and here's the other
thing Matthew one of the things we have
around here is if your broke friends are
making fun of your financial plan means
you're right on track
so you just you know if broke people are
arguing with you then you you're doing
the right thing so uh your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
as long as Sally May has her own spare
bedroom at your house as long as an
aviant lives in the basement uh you got
a problem they're sucking your paycheck
away and so you have to smack them in
the nose and get rid of them as fast as
you can it's vital that you get control
of your most powerful wealth building
tool because saving fifteen percent of
120 000 is no picnic but it can be done
if you don't have any payments yeah and
so when you prescribe rice and beans
beans and rice that is that is a
struggle but it is designed to
streamline you getting out of this
process and now it's all just compound
interest in investing and doing those
things you talked about and so that's
that's the thing you got to understand
uh there's a reason why you say you have
no life it's to get done as fast as
possible get through the storm as
quickly as possible you know what you
can do if you got to three or four
million dollars and no debt a lot more
than you can do in your oh you know I
mean you got these choices you got
options in and that's the idea that's
what we're wanting to take you to we
want you to be a baby steps millionaire
so um and that's the next step after you
get through this stuff so it's it is
hard it is living like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
that one's the Bible that wasn't me